foreign
[Music]
what do we know about the concept of
work
is there just one meaningful work let's
find out a boy has done certain
activities like washing the dishes
writing a letter to someone and brushing
his teeth
are the boys following activities
considered as work
if your answer is yes then you are right
and wrong
you are probably wondering how could you
be right and wrong at the same time
well let's see why
you are right because the general
concept of work could apply to any sort
of activity that requires energy but in
the scientific perspective it is known
to be zero amount of work
so what is considered as work in the
scientific perspective
let's try out an example to understand
this
an evil monster was to destroy a city
but it doesn't go straight to the city
to destroy it instead he takes a huge
Boulder next to him aims it at a
specific Direction and throws it
destroying a part of the city
is the activity done by the monster
considered as work in scientific terms
if your answer is yes then you are right
granted it was a bad kind of work but it
was work nonetheless
so what were the fundamental aspects
done to consider this as work
why did I say that works done here
there are two requirements that should
be met for work to be done
one force needs to be applied on the
object
two the object needs to be displaced
if an object does not meet these two
conditions together then it isn't
considered as work
when the monster threw the boulder at
the city he applied force on it and
threw it in a specific Direction and
hence displaced it
[Music]